After my last post, I got a couple new followers
so I wanted to introduce myself.
Um, my name is Lisa.
I am a 37 year old mom of 3.
I'm a stay at home mom. I homeschool my older 2 kids.
I have a 9 8 and two and a/2 year old.
I also have a degree in socio cultural anthropology
as well as a background in culinary.
I don't really share cooking on here,
it's just a different type of content.
But I do do a lot of deep dives on social norms,
on cultural phenomenon, on issues pertaining to feminism,
womanhood, parenthood in this country as well.
Um, if you're interested in more of the deep divey topics,
I do have a season of a podcast that you can find in my link tree
that really goes more in depth
into a lot of these socio cultural norms,
including the white beauty standard and the um,
the pedophilic nature of the male gaze,
which was the conversation that those videos kind of blew up on.
But there's more there too.
So if you're into the deep dives,
like that's a great place to go as well.
Um, if you are following along,
I don't just share deep dives,
I definitely share a lot of parenting content,
a lot of gentle parenting content,
a lot of inner child healing journey stuff,
a lot of homeschooling resources,
a little bit of my day to day life as a stay at home Mom.
A lot of feminist content,
as well as a lot of deconstructing content.
Um, and then style and fashion,
because we're also kind of a fashion girly.
So you can do all. You can do it all on here, right?
Women don't have to be just one thing.
So I, um,
talk a lot about a. A variety of topics.
You can find some playlists up above.
And I'm really glad you're here.
Whatever content brought you here,
I would love to hear in the comments
some of the things that you find interesting right now
and you would like to discuss,
because I love stretching our brains
and having these difficult and interesting conversations.
But thanks for following along. And that's me least be